you're doing sober November I actually
cannot recall the last time I did not
have a glass of wine you know what it'd
be really nice to give my body a break I
want to dedicate 30 days of just cold
turkey but I'm also want to wake up and
do meditation for 15 minutes today and
then also doing daily affirmations and I
know this sounds really cheesy but I yes
I do look at myself in the mirror and I
just say like three positive things
about myself like I you do yeah I think
it's really hard for us to get out of
our heads and kind of recenter I feel
like the last few months especially like
going through you know moving to a new
city being single again I'm like you
know what I really want to restart and
just see how my mental state is after
doing this if this is going to improve
my physical state cuz I want to just
feel good because I think if you feel
good you feel like you can accomplish
more things while you're doing no
alcohol November I'm doing No Shave
November so I'm really living up to
sorry suei